WELL, THE MUELLER REPORT IN
THE END DIDN'T QUITE REVEAL
WHAT THE LEFT PROMISED IT
WOULD.
SPENT TWO YEARS TELLING US IT
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
TAXPAYERS SPENT.
THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF
INVESTIGATION.
AND IN THE END, NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
SO IF YOU BOUGHT IN 100% TO
THE IDEA THAT THE MUELLER
REPORT IS GOING TO VINDICATE
ALL OF YOUR DREAMS, HOW DO YOU
RESPOND?
WELL, DENIAL WORKS.
SOME ARE PRETENDING IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
OUT IF HOLLYWOOD, A BUNCH OF
THE CELEBRITIES ARE FULLY IN
DENIAL.
THEY SAY THE REPORT DID EXPOSE
COLLUSION AND YOU COULD
DISCOVER IT, TOO, IF YOU'D
JUST READ ALL 448 PAGES
SLOWLY.
WATCH.
>> THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
ATTACKED OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> THEY INTERFERED IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IN
SWEEPING AND SYSTEMIC FASHION.
>> MADE HUNDREDS OF CONTACTS
WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> ALL THIS A PART OF THE
MASSIVE COVERT OPERATION.
>> INVESTIGATE CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN RUSSIA AND THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> MUELLER DELIVERED HIS
REPORT ON MARCH 22.
AND IT CONTAINS THE MOST
DAMNING EVIDENCE EVER COMPILED
AGAINST A SITTING
U.S. PRESIDENT.
>> YET, VIRTUALLY NO ONE HAS
READ IT.
>> AND BEFORE THE REPORT WAS
EVEN RELEASED TRUMP'S ATTORNEY
GENERAL WILLIAM BARR LIED
ABOUT ITS CONTENT.
>> ALL THIS IS IN THE REPORT.
PLEASE JUST READ IT FOR
YOURSELF.
>> NO ONE --
>> NOT EVEN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES --
>> IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> Tucker: WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF THOSE PEOPLE MOVE THEIR
LIPS WHEN THEY READ?
>> GREAT VOICES, THOUGH.
THAT IS FOR SURE!
TAMMY BRUCE!
[LAUGHTER]
IT MAKES ME LAUGH.
>> IT'S LIKE ROBERT De NIRO.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE JUST GOUT OUT
OF THE SHOWER AND WAS REALLY
UPSET OR SOMETHING IN THAT
IMAGERY.
THE ONLY THING MISSING FROM
THAT TONE AND THE NATURE OF
THIS WAS A DISCUSSION OF CROP
CIRCLES AND HIEROGLYPHICS AND
EGYPT AND THE PYRAMIDS WERE
COMMUNICATION TO THE OUTER
SPACE PEOPLE.
LOOK, THIS IS PATHETIC.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE EMBARRASSED AS
THEY SHOULD BE.
NOT JUST BECAUSE OF THE VIDEO
BUT BECAUSE THEY DID TELL
PEOPLE FOR YEARS THAT THIS WAS
GOING TO BE THE CASE.
IT WASN'T JUST ABOUT
COLLUSION.
IT WAS THAT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WAS A
RUSSIAN SPY.
BUT WHAT DO YOU EXPECT FROM
PEOPLE WHO MAKE A LIVING BY
LIVING IN MAKE BELIEVE?
AND THIS IS IT.
NOW THE OTHER THING, OF
COURSE, THE NEXT VIDEO THAT
COULD FOLLOW WOULD BE ALL OF
THEM TALKING ABOUT THAT THE
GOVERNMENT STILL HAS NOT
ARRESTED THE CORLEONE FAMILY,
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE HAD THREE
MOVIES EXPOSING WHAT IT IS
THEY HAVE DONE.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S TRUE!
YOU KNOW IT!
A FEW DAYS AGO WE HAD A NUMBER
OF SENATORS BRIEFED ON THE
U.F.O.s.
WE KNOW THERE WAS BRIEFING
ABOUT SOME OF THE NAVY
SIGHTINGS OF THE LIGHTS THEY
CAN'T EXPLAIN.
YET, DECADES AGO WE KNEW ABOUT
DARTH VADER AND PRINCESS LEAH
AND LUKE SKYWALKER AND WE DID
NOTHING ABOUT IT THEN EITHER.
THIS IS THE SAME TRAJECTORY.
THEY ARE TELLING PEOPLE, LOOK
AT THE MOVIE, READ THE BOOK
AND YOU WILL BELIEVE IT, TOO.
BUT IT'S ALSO INSULTING
BECAUSE THEY ARE BEHAVING AS
THOUGH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE OR
THEIR OWN CONSTITUENCY, OTHER
LIBERALS, OR ARE TOO LAZY TO
READ OR READ IT BUT DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND IT PROPERLY AND
HAVE GIVEN UP.
THAT THEY ARE THE ONLY ONES
WHO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
DYNAMIC IS.
THERE IS REHAB FOR PEOPLE IN
HOLLYWOOD WHO ESCAPE REALITY
USING DRUGS AND ALCOHOL.
THERE NOW NEEDS TO BE ONE TO
GET THEM OUT OF THIS
PATHOLOGICAL FIXIZATION ON
DONALD
FINALD
FIXILD
FIXIZATION --FIXIZATION ON DONAL
FIXIZATION --FIXIZATION ON DONAD
FIXIZATION --FIXIZATION ON DONAT
FIXIZATION --FIXIZATION ON DONAU
FIXIZATION --FIXIZATION ON DONAP
FIXIZATION --FIXIZATION ON DONA.
THEY NEED TO ACCEPT THEY ARE
WRONG, WHICH IS WHAT MOST
AMERICANS DO, AND MOVE ON.
>> IT MUST BE MORE BORING THAN
WE REALIZE TO BE AN ACTOR.
YOU THINK IF YOU ARE ROBERT
De NIRO YOU WOULD THINK I'M
ENJOYING MY 11 HOUSES AND THE
PRIVATE PLANE.
FRUITS OF MY LABOR.
I'M RICH AND FAMOUS.
BUT NO, HE IS SITTING IN A
STUDIO YELLING ABOUT TRUMP IN
A CAMERA.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE
FIXIZATION.
>> A LARGE PART OF THE PROBLEM
IS YOU HAVE A POLITICIAN AND
HOLLYWOOD WHO BEGAN TO BELIEVE
THEY ARE THE WOULD
THEY ARE THE OOULD
THEY ARE THE ONELD
THEY ARE THE ONESD
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT MATTER.
THEY ARE BETTER THAN EVERYBODY
ELSE.
WE'RE DEPLORABLE PLEBES OUT
HERE RUINING THINGS.
YET, WE DIDN'T LISTEN TO THEM
IN 2016.
WE REJECTED THEIR ADVICE.
WE DIDN'T TAKE THEM SERIOUSLY.
WE STILL AREN'T.
SO FOR THEM, IT'S THEIR -- IT
IS NEVER ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE
THE NARCISSISM IS TOO MUCH.
FOR THEM IT'S ABOUT THEIR OWN
SENSE OF SERIOUSEST IN
SENSE OF SERIOUSNET IN
SENSE OF SERIOUSNESSIN
SENSE OF SERIOUSNESS.N
THIS IS AN EFFORT TO
REGENERATE THEMSELVES.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
COUNTRY.
IT NEVER HAS.
>> Tucker: THE IRONY, OF
COURSE, IS THEIR INFLUENCE IS
WANING.
>> EXACTLY.
>> THE BUSINESS IS DYING.